España ha acordado con Estados Unidos
abrir sus fronteras a migrantes que sean
referidos desde los centros de
tramitación en distintos países de
latinoamérica como Colombia y Guatemala
cuya creación anunció este jueves el
departamento de estado y seguridad
nacional estadounidense desde el
Ministerio de inclusión seguridad social
y migraciones de España aseguran que la
colaboración pretende impulsar una
migración regular ordenada y segura
desde centro y Sudamérica que evite
viajes que en ocasiones se convierten en
peligrosos y que ponen a las personas
migrantes en situaciones de mayor
vulnerabilidad frente a las mafias
España colaborará con este proyecto
identificando y asesorando a personas
que puedan ser elegibles para alguna de
las vías de migración regular hacia el
país europeo como lo son por ejemplo la
reunificación Familiar o las peticiones
de asilo con este paso España Avanza en
el cumplimiento de uno de los puntos de
la declaración conjunta entre Madrid y
Washington de 2001 que fue renovada el
año pasado por el presidente del
gobierno español Pedro Sánchez y el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
en esta se comprometían a gestionar los
flujos migratorios irregulares y a
garantizar un trato justo y humano a
migrantes con un énfasis en los países
de América Latina y el Caribe de hecho
las relaciones con el centro y sur del
continente americano será uno de los
temas de discusión entre ambos líderes
que se reunirán el próximo 12 de mayo en
la Casa Blanca